[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone my name is nari sol i'm a
pianist composer and what you just heard
was a little tune i wrote this week
after spending some time listening to
retro video game music i first went into
this with a long list of suggestions
from you all including all kinds of
video game music but for now i narred it
down to 8-bit music
also known as chiptune
[Music]
some general characteristics that come
to mind are that a lot of these tunes
are very simple they're very catchy
they're very easy to recognize
[Music]
and there's little to no development and
i think that's because functionally
speaking these are tunes that accompany
a game whether it's while you're playing
it or before so i think that helps keep
that tune neutral to when you're hearing
it within that context of the game after
doing a lot of listening i went onto
youtube of course to look for tutorials
on how to simulate these sounds on logic
and i played around with that for quite
a bit
so let's start out with uh logic
quick on zero this one
takes a long time to fade out
so right now i'm just playing with the
different dials
and i'm experimenting with the different
sounds
[Music]
something i find very charming about a
lot of the tracks that i've been
listening to
is that there are a lot of effects
within the track that
maybe are effects within the the game
itself
maybe something like this
is a sort of laser beam i also hear a
lot of runs
something like that
there are a lot of other quirky sounds
that i can think of that
maybe are just characteristic of this
type of style
[Music]
there aren't too many instances where i
hear very thick full cords and i think
that's because of
the natural limitations of the type of
technology the decay or non-decay if you
said it that way
is not that pleasant
a lot of that also depends on the type
of melody for percussion i'm usually
hearing this noise
which is a sound created by pushing up
the noise toggle all the way up
to create this
static sound i also hear a lot of
repeated notes
whether it's going back and forth
between
two notes or
an octave
[Music]
those things being said i found this
genre to be very open to many different
possibilities not just within the
different sounds being used but also
with the different types of melodies
harmonies and styles within this genre
so here's just a very quick overview of
the different tracks that go into this
little tune of mine first of all the
percussion
i'm just using a very quick and dry
static sound
the bass line uses this type of sound
[Music]
a little more resonant
[Music]
on the off beats i'm going back and
forth between a minor third and a major
third
[Laughter]
also accompanying that i have this line
and on the top i'm using this type of
sound
[Music]
i'm also using this for effects such as
this run
and chords like this
and that's about it anyway thank you so
much for watching i really appreciate
all of your comments i read through them
i try my best
and also if you're interested in my book
or sheet music from these videos check
out my website
[Music]
you